right 5 and 1/4 as an improper fraction
and an improper fraction is just a pure
fraction where the numerator is greater
than the denominator this right here
it's not a pure fraction we have a whole
number mixed with the fraction so we
call this a mixed number so let's think
about what 5 and 1/4 represents and let
me rewrite it so if we're talking about
5 and 1/4 5 and 1/4 and you can
literally think of this as 5 and 1/4 or
5 plus 1/4 that's what 5 and 1/4
represents so let's think about 5 5 is 5
holes or if you're thinking of pie we
could draw literally 5 pies we could
draw 5 pie so let me just cut up the
pies from the get-go into 4 pieces since
we're dealing with fourths so let me
just cut up the pies right over here so
that's 1 pie right over there let me
copy and paste this copy and paste so I
have two pies and then I have three pies
and then I have four pies and then I
have five pies so this is what the five
represents five literally represents so
let me circle all of this together that
is the five part right there that is
what five literally represents it
represents five whole pies five whole
pies now I have cut up the pies into
four pieces so you can imagine each
piece represents a fourth now how many
pieces do I have in these five pies well
I have four pieces per pie I have four
pieces per pie four pieces per pie four
pieces well let me just write it here
four pieces per pie times times five
pies is equal to 20 20 pieces or another
way to think of it since each piece is
1/4 this is also equal to 20 times 1/4
or you could just write this as be equal
to 20 fourths so we have five whole pies
is equal to 20 24th
let me write it like that twenty-fourths
or we could write it as we can write it
as 20 over 4 I've kind of done the same
thing twice so that's what the five pies
represent twenty-fourths or 20 pieces
where each piece is 1/4
now the 1/4 right here represents
literally one more fourth of a pie or
one more piece of a pie so let me draw
another pie here so let me draw another
pie here so that is another pie cut it
into 4 pieces but this 1/4 only
represents one one of these pieces right
this is one of the 4 pieces the 4 the
denominator tells us how many pieces the
one tells us how many of those pieces
were dealing with so it's just this one
piece over here that right there is the
1/4 now if we write 5 and 1/4 we just
saw that the 5 the 5 right here is 20
fourths so we could write this so we
could rewrite this so let me write it
like this 5 and 1/4 5 and 1/4 can be
re-written as this is the same thing as
5 plus 1/4 5 plus 1/4 which is the same
thing as we just saw that 5 whole pie is
the same thing as 20 fourths
twenty-fourths and to see that these are
the same thing you literally just divide
4 into 20 you get 5 and nothing is left
over so 5 is the same thing is
twenty-fourths and then this plus 1/4
the same thing as plus 1/4
so if I have twenty-fourths and I add
one more fourth to it how many fourths
do I have well I have 21
I have 21 fourths or another way of
thinking about it this 5 is so this
right here is that right there is 20
pieces 20 pieces of
and you can even count it 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 but
the quicker way is to say well we have 5
pies each of them have 4 pieces
5 times 4 is 20 this 1/4 right here
represents one piece plus one piece so
total we're going to have 21 21 pieces
so we have 21 pieces where each piece is
1/4 so you could say we have 21 times
1/4 or 21 fourths pieces of pie however
you want to think of it but we've we've
solved the problem we're at an improper
fraction we've written 5 and 1/4 is an
improper fraction now I've gone through
great pains to give you the intuition of
what 5 and 1/4 means but there is a
fairly straightforward process for
getting straight to the improper
fraction if you have if you have let me
color code it so if you have 5 + 1 / 5 +
1 / 4 to convert it into an improper
fraction
you literally you're going to keep the
same denominator so you're going to have
the / 4 there but your numerator is
going to be your your de not your your
numerator of the fraction part before so
it's going to be 1 plus your whole
number times your denominator so 1 plus
or actually let me do it the way I tend
to think of it what I do is I take 4
times 5 so let me write that down 4 and
I want to color code it 4 times 5 4
times 5 and then to that I add to that I
add this numerator so I literally do 4
times 5 plus 1 and which is so this is
equal to 4 times 5 is 20 plus 1 is 21
and that's over 4 so it's 21 forts and
although this is kind of a fast way to
do it we're literally doing the exact
same thing that we did here in kind of a
slower way we're saying ok 5 holes is
the same thing as twenty-fourths so you
take 5 and I figure that out times 5
times 4 and then I have one more fourth
there so 4 times 5 plus 1 gets 20
one